ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show live from dubai our new home
our new set we're very excited to be
broadcasting building a comedy scene in
the united arab emirates this is our new
studio it's here and we are here
queering the space
of podcasting uh every day and it's
suicidal to be a podcaster now because
it is the golden age of tv i don't know
if you've seen that article there are
599 scripted shows more than at any
point uh in our nation's history there
are
599 uh scripted shows it's on drudge
it is the golden age of tv there are
more streaming services more shows
that no one watches so it's crazy for us
uh scripted series volume hits all-time
high in 2021.
the annual estimate of shows from fx
jumps 13
after a one-year dip in 2020 but the
shows are back tv is back no one knows
what that means
no one knows how to watch any of these
shows but uh
there are a lot
of television shows like bull
have you seen bull
look up bull
bull
it's a drama
why is bull being canceled
in may 2020 bull was renewed for fifth
season with the further announcement in
october 2020 that the season would be
trimmed to 16 episodes well that's not
enough bull
what is bull about dr jason bull is the
charming and cocky founder of a
successful trial consulting firm trial
analysis corporation where he and his
team of experts employ psychology human
intuition and high-tech data to
understand jurors lawyers witnesses and
defendants and construct effective
narratives to help their clients win
bull's team includes his brother-in-law
benny
linguistics expert marissa former
detective danny hacker cable and chunk
who helps perfect clients appearances
for trial
bull is inspired by the early career of
dr phil mcgraw
who also serves as an executive producer
bull is the story of dr phil
113 episodes
113 episodes of dr phil's origin story
so thank you for spending time with us
here
instead of bull
we're here in los angeles california
where people are being murdered in
furniture stores this is a tragic
situation a young woman was at her job
at a furniture store and ended up
getting stabbed to death
and this is insane they're asking for
help the lapd is asking for help solving
furniture store employee killing
on la brea in hancock park it's like a
nice area of la this is a high-end
furniture store this is the problem with
a lot of what's going on right now the
supply chain is wreaking havoc and if
you tell somebody they're going to get a
sectional in six months and they don't
have it they're getting emotional and
they're going in and they're taking it
out on the store employees and this is
not right and this is a tragic situation
the state is descending into hell
very quickly and there's nothing funny
about this um
the suspect attacked a victim with a
knife and fled the scene through the
back door the suspect was seen on
security video casually walking down the
back alley of the business he's
described as a black male unknown age
tall thin wearing a dark hoodie
sunglasses a white n95 mask responsible
dark skinny jeans dark shoes carrying a
dark backpack
well
based on evidence discovered by
detectives the suspect is believed to be
homeless now this is weird because
i i'm under the impression that all
people without homes are inherently good
that's the impression that i've been
under is that all people
that are living in a tent
or don't have a house
or are spending most of their time out
on the street are good people it's odd
that one of them
uh
stabbed a woman to death in a furniture
store but apparently
not all of these homeless people are
thrilled with being homeless it's not
all fun and games
you know
echo park which is a part of los angeles
they had this like homeless encampment
there and it was this you know fantasy
uh uh of uh you know this utopian
fantasy where liberal white women would
go and deliver avocados to a lot of
these people some of them hopelessly
addicted to fentanyl and uh every now
and then there'd be a knife fight or an
overdose but uh people really love the
community and it was sad when the
community was destroyed um but what we
have to start realizing is that a lot of
these homeless people sadly uh seem to
be unwell they don't seem to be doing
great and having them walk around the
city with knives is probably not good
is that okay to say
is that all right to say or am i gonna
piss someone off
is someone mad at that is the stabbing
good or bad
is the homeless guy stabbing the woman
in the furniture store a net positive or
a net negative
i think it might be bad
and that makes me an alarmist boomer
psychopath obsessed with the crime
statistics just because i think someone
might should have the right to work at a
furniture store and you know these
people they're hearing [ __ ] all day from
people like me that walk and go where's
a [ __ ] couch and they're screaming
and yelling and i'm not even saying
these furniture store people should be
treated uh exceptionally well
truly i mean we're all [ __ ] spending
a lot of money and none of us are
getting our [ __ ] so we're angry but you
should stop short of stabbing them right
i mean you shouldn't do that you
shouldn't separate them from their
consciousness
um
but again we've got a real problem
uh in in the city of los angeles and and
people that pointed out
um
are themselves uh targeted for being uh
alarmists and crazy but
you know r.i.p to this young woman this
is a [ __ ] tragedy
i completely understand
um
you know now and so then then we have
the lapd to go well what is the lapd
doing well the lapd
god help us
this is a quote from the lapd two los
angeles cops fired for ignoring robbery
to chase a snorlax
in pokemon go
which is rare the snorlax is the big fat
pokemon and it's rare
and
so this is what happened la police
department officers louis lozano and
eric mitchell were fired for ignoring a
robbery in progress because they were
too busy chasing a snorlax they appealed
their termination and corp were denied
the official court opinion document is
really something else for example
this is what it says for approximately
the next 20 minutes the digital in-car
video system in the squad car captured
petitioners discussing pokemon as they
drove to different locations where the
virtual creatures apparently appeared on
their mobile phone so this is who we're
hiring on the police force
this is also part of the problem
the police are playing pokemon go a game
that hasn't been hot for three years
okay
wait till they discovered augmented
react like the new [ __ ] coming down the
pike i mean can you imagine
where these wait till they find out
about twitch
i mean nothing will get done
so on their way to the snorlax location
because snorlax if you haven't played
pokemon go these are creatures they're
pokemon and you gotta catch them all
not criminals
but the pokemon gotta catch em all
sadly snorlax wasn't in that furniture
store where that woman was getting
beheaded
so officer mitchell alerted officer
lozano that uh a uh uh a tiger
t-o-g-e-t-i-c
just popped up
no i don't know what that means noting
that it was on crenshaw just south of
50th after mitchell apparently caught
the snorlax exclaiming got him
petitioners again not the criminal the
snorlax petitioners agreed to go get the
whatever that is and drove off but when
their car stopped again the
the camera recorded mitchell saying
don't run away don't run away while
lozano described how he quote buried it
and ultra bald
the i don't know what that word is it's
a pokemon the togetic okay turgetic is a
pokemon so he buried it in ultra ball
the tergetic before announcing got him
mitchell advised he was quote still
trying to catch it adding holy crap man
this thing is fighting the crap out of
me
oh god
eventually mitchell exclaimed holy crap
finally apparently in reference to
capturing the tejada key remark the guys
are going to be so jealous the guys
meaning the other cops are doing this as
well
the guys they're not ashamed of this
activity they're not ashamed of this
behavior this is clout for them they're
going to go back to the squad and tell
everybody that they caught a snorlax
this is the lapd the los angeles police
department petitioners then agreed to
return to the 7-eleven where sergeant
gomes later met them to end their watch
on the way mitchell remarked i got you a
new pokemon today dude so this is what
the lapd has been doing
they have been out trying to catch
pokemon go
while the city burns
this is proof
this is not probably a unique situation
many of them are bragging to the other
ones look at the pokemon i just got
while people are getting stabbed to
death uh on the showroom of a furniture
store
this is a problem
this is a who are we hiring to be police
by the way what is the psychological
examination required to be a police
officer apparently not much
really it's it's pretty sickening to
hear this
petitioners also denied playing pokemon
go while on duty they claim they were
monitoring monitoring a quote pokemon
tracker application on their phone but
not playing the game
so again they are monitoring the pokemon
tracker while on duty
as police
as for catching pokemon officer lozano
insisted this referred to quote
capturing an image of the pokemon on the
tracking application to share with
friends while officer mitchell said in
his statements about fighting the
tragedic referred to quote relaying that
information to the groups on my app
adding that in order to take the picture
occasionally the creature will fight
lozano said they were not engaged in a
game rather it was quote a social media
event well that's a problem too
and it was a game we know they're just
trying to cover their ass mitchell said
he did not consider the application a
game because it was quote not advertised
as a game petitioners admittedly leave
imagine this
imagine all the cops that have been let
go over the last few years for shooting
innocent people
overreacting police brutality corruption
things like that imagine these two
idiots
somehow getting fired for catching a
pokemon
petitioners admitting uh they admitted
leaving their foot beat area in search
of snorlax but they insisted they did so
both as part of an extra patrol
and to chase the mythical creature so
they said this was kind of a kill two
birds with one stone operation we did a
little extra patrol and then it just so
happened that we were trying to catch
the snorlax imagine going home and
telling your wife why you got why you
got popped at work why you got thrown
out
it was because you were trying to catch
a snorlax
now look at snorlax he's a big guy so
this is the togetic that's togepi yeah
that's rare togetic is rare but snorlax
take a look at snorlax he's a big
powerful pokemon and i don't need any
comments here like oh you're snorlax we
don't need that in the youtube we don't
need that that's not productive but that
snore like i uh there's a bit my friend
is a big snorlax pillow which kind of
cool it's like a chair um but he's also
mentally ill but he has a snorlax chair
in his home and he's an adult
logan paul i think they just beat him on
three and a half million dollars of fake
pokemon cards really
yeah
i watched gary vee on the full send
podcast very interesting about nfts
we're having dinner with gary which will
be uh exciting and i'm excited about
that and we'll either he's either gonna
poison us or we're gonna leave there
with a new business that we've started
with him we don't know
but i was watching that full cent
podcast about
nfts and
about you know the possibilities of what
nfts will be in the future and it was a
uh
it was an interesting thing in our
friend john shahidi's big into those
nfts big into collecting things and i
think gary was pretty honest he said you
know 98 of projects in the nft world are
going to zero meaning they'll be worth
nothing but then there's two percent of
projects that'll be worth something and
then the technology behind this all web
will somehow be inevitable
web 2 does feel like it's at the end
right go on facebook and and see web 2.
web 2 is your family
on facebook
sharing photos and opinions
uh about their life and ideas and that
does feel like we've had just quite
about enough of web too
it makes more sense to trade apes back
and forth than to listen to your uncle
sound off
on the state of uh the affairs
so web 2 is on its way out and in comes
web 3. you can now own things digitally
you may be able to own an nft of
something and if we did an nft line we'd
want to give people more [ __ ] than just
an image we'd want to give them maybe an
exclusive podcast or tickets to a show
you know it's all about the community
yeah this is what i hear and it's all
about the community that's why are you
laughing that's what it is it's about
the community it's the community it's
about building a community we don't have
families anymore so you got to build a
community there's no knights of columbus
nobody can nobody goes bowling there was
a great book called bowling alone so we
have to build a community around apes
the photos of apes
because that's how communities are built
in the digital space i have a gutter cat
look up gutter cat this is a community i
have a gutter cat and you have a gutter
cat we should be friends
it's the creation of uh communities so
there's a gutter i kind of want a gutter
cat 12 000 of them these are cool
they're a little cheaper than the uh
apes which are now trading in the three
or four hundred thousand
dollar range
at least these communities are not based
solely on hate which is the political
communities right
i mean it's better than that
the hype beasts are are better than
january 6
right if the people at january 6 instead
of running uh into the uh
capitol building and taking selfies in
the gayest and dumbest revolution ever
in the history of the world if instead
of doing that they just went to a place
and showed each other their gutter cats
that would be better
that would be an improvement
it would be an improvement if a bunch of
those people if antifa instead of
burning down buildings uh met somewhere
and showed each other their shoes that
would be better so maybe this is how we
have to create communities because the
way we're creating them right now isn't
good we're venerating genocidal
ideologies that have long been
discredited and we're going out into the
streets to raise hell
all to no effect we're not causing any
positive change nobody's lives are
actually better than they were two years
ago
the government
is completely unaffected by most of this
they just kind of egg it on they're not
threatened by any of it they're egging
it on they kind of like it they kind of
like people being scared and divided so
none of this is a revolution in the
sense that the government is changing
any of their operating principles so it
seems to be just a way for a lot of
people to blow off steam well if you're
going to blow off steam and end up in
jail for 10 years federal prison
why don't you just get a [ __ ] ape
go get a gutter cat
go get a lazy lion
and just show people that you own the
thing that they own i own this you own
that i was criticized for the community
of tesla owners which you're a part of
because many of them are insane and many
of their identity has become spacex and
elon musk you own a [ __ ] car but it
doesn't matter because now they're in a
community and they have little meetup
groups where these psychopaths go and
they rate the different electronic
charging stations and what's better and
well that one usually has a line and why
what restaurants have electronic
charging i want to charge my tesla while
i eat and they have all these [ __ ]
horrible
strange weird things that they discuss
because their life uh
centers around the [ __ ] car they
drive so if we're gonna do that we're
gonna build these communities digital
communities then maybe we should just
build them around pictures of animals
what's wrong with that
i don't see anything inherently wrong
with that
perhaps it's a scam but it's certainly
no worse than any other scam that's been
out there
i'm excited for this dinner i want to
come out of it i want to be an nft
trillionaire
if it gives people more freedom i'm in
that's why i look at crypto people go
where do you where do you stand on it
are you making fun of it or do you like
it hey
i'm
here's where i am with it if it
increases people's freedom
and it allows people
creators consumers to do more [ __ ] and
they don't have to rely on legacy
institutions that are rotting and
crumbling and have all been you know uh
perverted by all kinds of different
financial incentives and ideologies if
you can detach and get away from all
that and support the people that you
like and creators and artists and people
can issue these nfts as a way to build
their own
um you know brand and build their own
career outside of a hopelessly corrupt
system than good
if it's just a pump and dump scheme well
then good too
if people pump and dump at the right
time
but if you're looking at it long term
you go i hope just like patreon just
like any of these things that have
allowed people to have careers outside
of the myth the reason that we're hated
by the way
and rogan's taking a lot of heat now
because apparently he said a few things
about this vaccine have you heard any of
that i haven't
apparently he's weighed in on this uh
this vaccine controversy i have not
heard anything about it but uh
he uh is getting a lot of flack
and he's taken some positions that
people don't like but the bigger reason
that they hate him and a lot of them
don't like me and they hate people that
are making a living on the internet
whether it's podcasting or doing
whatever
is because most of the people in
hollywood live and fear
everyone in this town whether they have
a hundred million dollars or no money
they live in fear
they live in fear of losing their job
they live in fear of becoming irrelevant
they live in fear of not being able to
satiate the blood thirsty mob on twitter
that's why a lot of comedians we know
spend most of their time apologizing for
past indiscretions they deliver pound of
flesh to the mob pound of flesh to the
mob the mob chews it up patent oswald
does a guest spot on dave chappelle's
show people go you transphobic
and he's got to write his soliloquy's
got to write the beginning of a novel i
never well i must continue to educate
myself on them i hold forth these truths
to be self-evident i
and they live in fear and they live in
fear because their money gets turned on
and off like a faucet
they turn the money on they turn the
money off and when they turn the money
on things are good things are good
there's big houses in those feliz with
swimming pools there's red carpets
there's people that care there's a
profiles in the new york times what
makes you tech how did you get so funny
did you always know you're a funny how
does that work like you're like so
creative i wish i was you
what is your [ __ ] taste like does it
taste as creative as you and they write
all these articles about you when you're
great you're the first woman to ever do
anything how does it feel how does it
fail to be the first woman to ever walk
the earth and all of these articles get
written and people get really excited
they get really excited and they and you
know you go into the coffee shop and
people go
oh it's
it's
excited the barista gets excited you
walk in they go oh yeah i didn't want to
see anything but i know who you are and
you know i just say oh you know
and you get excited and you start
[ __ ] people that are way out of your
league people that are much more
attractive than you want to have sex
with you because you're famous and and
that's the elixir that's the drug the
fame and the fact that you matter and
you matter largely because
an industry of people decided you should
matter
they had a meeting and decided in a room
that what you say should matter well
over the last few years the ability of
them to do that has waned
they can't do that as much and a lot of
those people that were famous and rich
they were coasting and they were told
exactly what to say and how to say it
and they didn't say anything with ruffle
feathers and they stayed in the line of
this just kind of you know mainstream
liberal like you know
after school special kind of hallmark
movie feel good [ __ ] and then retire to
their mansions to do blow and have fun
now what's happening is you have all
these new people on the internet whose
views and ideas are much more in line
with the american public number one we
have views and ideas right we have
thoughts and those thoughts are actually
more mainstream than a lot of these
hollywood actors and comedians that
don't think at all and have made a
career not really thinking
um about anything in a way that could
upset or hurt their career so when they
go and do podcasts they don't really do
well because they're
scripted and it's odd and stilted and
they get on there and they basically try
to just they they're not authentic and
people can smell it and feeling well
this isn't really working
um
and and and and hollywood right now and
academia they've kind of been captured
they've been captured
by kind of radicals right people that
hold views that are vastly different
from the majority of the american people
and when you
when most people in hollywood don't
really have these views they just want
to be rich but then there are a few
people that have these views and want
these views telegraphed in every piece
of art so if you want to be in any of
these things you have to either hold
these views or quietly abstain from ever
challenging them but that doesn't work
online right it doesn't really work
because people want authenticity they
want you to be real and say the [ __ ]
that you feel and think which is what
joe rogan does it's what i do it's what
people do and you take heat for it and
you take flack but it works and we make
money and we sell tickets and the people
that are part of that old system that
are kind of dying are angry about
they're not thrilled with that this has
never been a business where people
really
enjoy each other's success that's not
really what it is i mean you know watch
the awards show somebody went up but
like
whatever
people really just want each other to
fail there's not enough seats at the
table
so these people are angry and they're
mad and then they're trying to grab the
attention of tech and going shut them
down shut it off
shut this off now
shut it off we want them to watch things
that we make
now we need them to know that we are the
only option for entertainment so that's
why i read a million tweets a day that
their subtweet you know they're always
going at me you know in rap they would
be like it's subliminals they'd call me
all these names well i didn't get into
comedy to be rush limbaugh
you know never mind the positions i
advocate are vastly different from from
most mainstream conservatives i don't
like people getting stabbed at the
furniture store i do think that's wrong
that's now made me right wing i i don't
i don't realize where left wing became
pro stabbing at the furniture store but
this is this is what you see happening
but they don't care about facts or
reality they just care that i have money
and viewers and they don't
and that's really what it comes down to
with rogan rogan has the platform you
know so all these doctors sign this
letter to spotify like the
misinformation is it's wrong
and what rogue is doing is having
conversations with people that have a
different view of how coveted should be
treated many of them are advocating
early treatment instead of vaccines now
you can have that debate
you can have that conversation you
shouldn't shut it down
you you don't have to be an anti-vaxxed
lunatic to entertain a reasonable
conversation the vast majority i think
of people that watch and enjoy rogan are
probably vaccinated i'm vaccinated a lot
of people are vaccinated but also at the
third booster when everyone's sick it's
it's all so reasonable to have a
conversation about are these things
working as well as you wanted them to
work
um
but so so this is why you have the
problems that you have and they will
continue they'll continue until someone
wins
it could be the internet it could be i
don't know who's going to win
i'm you know i've hedged my bets
you know i don't know what's gonna
happen
um
but that's why
people are angry they're angry because
if they're forced
to compete in our world where they
themselves have to have thoughts
opinions and ideas and make them funny
and be authentic which is something
they've never done and don't know how to
do
their creations they don't exist they're
a character they've been playing for a
very long time well then they're going
to fail miserably so they need to be in
a world where they're protected and
insulated from that
you don't know what any of these people
and i i don't want to know what actors
think either i just want to have this
stop attacking us
i don't want to know what people i don't
i don't want to know what timothy
chalamet thinks about trade
let them do whatever they're going to do
entertain us that's fine but the anger
seems to be sort of one way i don't care
that i'm not on bull
but every comic
and all of these people can't stand that
there's now options out there people
don't have to listen to them people
don't have to buy a ticket to see them
it doesn't matter how many puff pieces
they run
on them at the times or wherever
people have options and that's what they
hate
if you've ever wanted to make your home
feel safer there's no better time than
now literally
right now our friends that simply safe
we're giving timbaland show listeners
access to all their new year's holiday
deals 20 off their award-winning home
security and your first month is free
when you sign up for the interactive
monitoring service we love simply safe
it has everything you need to make your
home safe indoor and outdoor cameras
comprehensive sensors all monitored
around the clock by trained
professionals who send help the instinct
you needed simply safe was even named
best home security system of 2021 by u.s
news and world report you can easily
customize a system for your home online
in minutes
and even get free custom recommendations
right now
there's a little bit of a crime wave you
know crime is up you got to protect
yourself there are no long-term
contracts or commitments it's really
easy to start feeling a bit more peace
of mind in the new year hurry
take 20 off your simply save system and
your first month is free when you sign
up for the interactive monitoring
service visit simplysafe.com
tim dillon again that's simply save dot
com slash tim dillon for 20 off your
entire system i have
simply safe
in texas
and i am
thrilled with
all of the
uh with the with the features well
there's sensors there's cameras well the
quote when you come is trying to break
into the house
and they have she was it was a tripwire
and a laser and they got her out of
there but
thank god you've got back-to-back
meetings errands to run and chores to
take care of what's the secret to
clearing your to-do list a little help
from doordash you can get dinner
household essentials and everything on
your grocery list delivered ever pulling
your tribe and this is a great thing
because people go well i'm fat you know
like because i'm eating uh postmates and
doordash and all this stuff but
why are you giving me a look like we're
gonna have to cut it out no we're not
we're not i'm saying but you can also
get healthy food and groceries delivered
as well you don't have to use these
services to get unhealthy food you can
get groceries delivered and that way you
can take your uh
daughter to dance and the son of
lacrosse or your son the dance and your
daughter lacrosse it's all great it's
all fine just get them out of the house
who cares what they're doing
it's time to get back out there we're
not quite we're not quite ready are you
ready i'm not ready i need another eight
ten years
if you're not quite ready for a
full-blown adventure there's still ways
to explore the world for the comfort of
your home with door dash you don't need
to travel to experience something new
you get a new cuisine
ooh it's friday let's try indian i want
a samosa you don't have to leave your
house and getting uh you know in a
situation that you don't want to be in
all
along with the restaurants you love you
can now get groceries and other
essential items stock up the house
deodorant toilet tissue broccoli
whatever you need get drinks snacks
get it all in under an hour craving late
night ice cream forget that one in key
ingredient for dinner maybe you just
need to stock up for the week with
doordash get everything in one app
with over 3 000 partners you can support
your neighborhoods go-to's or choose
from your favorite national chain
restaurants like popeyes chipotle or
cheesecake factory ordering is easy and
your items will be left safely outside
your door and what i like about the
doordash interface is you see the
pictures of what you're ordering
are you not impressed by that i do like
that it's a nice feature
do you use this i do yeah i prefer
doordash to all the other ones this
one's the best one for a limited time
our listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more when you download the
doordarshan app and enter code tim
dillon that's 25 off up to a 10 value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordarshan
app in the app store and enter go tim
dillon don't forget that's good tim
dillon for 25 off your first order with
doordash subject to change and of course
term supply
i want to apologize to australia because
i know i said that you all were um
um criminals and lazy and that's largely
true but a ten-year-old girl already
owns two companies and could retire at
15 as a multi-millionaire and she's
australian
right so i was wrong she's the creator
of pixies fidgets
a toy company originally bankrolled by
the late jeffrey epstein pixies fidgets
pixies fidgets made over 140 000 in the
first month according to news.com.edu
pixies
fidgets despite being still in
elementary school an australian girl is
on her way to retiring multi-millionaire
ten-year-old pixie curtis set up a toy
company that's already making huge
profits with the help of her mother roxy
jacinto pixie foundation so here's what
happened this girl didn't really do it
right her family did it and they said we
need to put a 10 year old as the face of
this company
isn't that what happened
it seems that way i bet uh this girl and
i'm sure she's a lovely woman but i
don't believe she built this
multi-million dollar business herself
right i mean this is probably her
parents
and um
they probably said you know what's a
really great story what's a great
narrative is our australian daughter who
how old is she she's 15 now but she
started it when she was 10. right she
didn't so 15 she's already a drunk
and she's already drunk and she's racist
and she's screaming about aboriginals
and land we know what her deal is you
know she's already probably drinking and
she's like oh i am [ __ ] war where are
you [ __ ] it
it's hard to do the australian
access law is law maybe it's like this
it's hard because when i start doing
access like i'm not australian every now
and then it just starts going into like
i i done to this and then i yeah how are
you doing like it goes somewhere else i
just can't stay with one because i'm so
cultured i go around the world but uh
yet pixie uh we're supposed to believe
that this 10 year old started a com none
of this is true right what is this a tax
scam what is this she didn't start
anything at 10
what are we talking about
our family joe cause i'll be working
until i'm 100 and pixie will [ __ ] at
15. i certainly know who's smarter
that's what the mother said but that's
not true
how does she start a company at 10 i
call i call
to [ __ ]
pixie story has gained a large following
on social media i'm asking more than 100
000 followers on instagram despite her
success her mother doesn't want pixie to
feel that she has to work for the
company what
isn't it her company
isn't it pixie's company or are you
lying
i've said it for day one the moment
pixie doesn't want to be front-facing or
involved with pixie's picks and pixies
bows then we will reassess but for now
she's happy learning so much the minute
she just wants to sit in the backyard
drinking will let her do that
what is pixi's picks i'm trying to
figure out
oh it's
it's what do they
they they just sell
toys
so how does this work they buy the toys
from china or something and then sell
them they probably have chinese chinese
factories make them and send them to
them yeah and then because it was
started by a ten-year-old girl
uh people go oh oh good
it's fun
pixies fidgets
i bet
like 10 year olds are also making this
oh so it's stress balls for children
it's stress balls for children some of
it for
can you go on can you go on the
the heart bumpy stress ball what a
dystopian nightmarish
toy
it's stress balls for kids
children
who are stressed out
instead of trying to figure out a way to
make them unstressed
we're giving them balls to squeeze
when they're terrified
that's what pixi's fidgets is
is that is that what it mean like pixie
fidgets i think to keep your mind yes
you can just fidget because you're
your your your head is filled with
existential dread from from the moment
you wake up to the moment you collapse
in your bed in a cold sweat so what you
can do is fidget all day with these toys
yeah there's the section for poppets so
like you have a pencil case and you can
just hit the hit the pops so this whole
entire line of toys is being marketed to
uh children with emotional problems
is that fair to say
fat brain toys simple dimple what is
that
what is a fat brain toy so these are for
babies to chew on
oh these are for babies that can't
control themselves
but that's what uh pixies fidgets is
it's for children that have
emotional issues
and they need to squeeze things i'm not
against this but
it is just a sign of the times
that a lot of the uh toys being marketed
to children now are some form of
like prozac plato
or whatever that they need to play with
like it's not just a toy
it's a way to relieve the all the stress
you have at nine
interesting
pixies fidgets
we're we're we're doubling down on the
mental illness here yeah we're doubling
we're not trying to get rid of any of it
we're we're actually going the other way
going how much more of it can we get
and can we mark it
because as soon as a capitalist machine
gets into place baby
everybody will be mentally ill
if you don't have a mental illness
you're uh you'll be a nazi soon
having a clear head
will mean you're a fascist
you better get them out and i see in
comedy all these white guys get up
they're like man i'm just [ __ ]
anxiety depression bipolar trip i'm just
[ __ ] up because and some of them are
unquestionably but some of them aren't
like these guys you go i'm bisexual it's
like you're not
you're not
somebody start your ticket college once
when you're drunk you're not you have a
[ __ ] girlfriend stop trying to save
your career by saying you're bisexual
you have to have sex you just have to
upload videos of you [ __ ] dudes and
getting [ __ ] by dudes
if you're claiming to be bisexual to get
to get a spot on uh one of these shows
so so i mean god bless pixie and her
fidgets
this is for like greta thundberg
when she gets stressed out about the
ozone layer she can sit around and
squeeze the stress ball and pop the
pencil case
this is for her
this is for greta
that's nice
days after one million dollar smash and
grab the great lori lightfoot walked out
of a meeting with quote idiot luxury car
dealer and then a city inspector showed
up with a ticket book you followed this
more than me we love lori lagford we
support her
a batman villain a dick tracy villain uh
one of the greatest mayors of one of our
greatest cities chicago um where the
murder rate i believe is like uh half
it's like one out of every two people
just get shot
the murder rate is literally half it's a
pie chart where half of it is uh dead
bodies what is going on with lori uh so
this guy joe pirillo at gold coast
exotic motor showroom uh he got a uh one
million dollars in luxury watches stolen
from on december 11th
he's a well-known car dealer in town he
went on the local national tv news
programs demanding that the city and
county take immediate steps to curb
crime
lori was not pleased with this now how
did he get the watches stolen
uh people just broke in it's one of
those things
they broke into where the car dealership
and what does he got he's got a million
dollar dollars where the watch is in the
car dealership i think some of the
showrooms have like exotic interesting
okay yeah you gotta sell the lifestyle
so pirillo got lightfoot's attention
days after the smash and grab lightfoot
walked into prilla showroom where
rolls-royce lamborghini and bentley
models are on display she wasn't there
to buy
instead she met with pirillo and
according to two sources familiar with
the conversation it did not go well one
said that the famously abrasive mara got
into a fight and walked out i love her
i'll vote for her i'll commit voter
fraud to vote for her
i may buy a house in chicago to vote for
her
a day or two after lightfoot walked out
prilo's dealership received another
visitor from the city an inspector from
the department of business affairs at
consumer protection she brought her
ticket book what's great about chicago
is it's hopelessly corrupt and in a way
that doesn't even try to disguise that
lightfoot spokesperson said the
inspector was following up on an
anonymous complaint who made that
that the city received on december 15th
about a public health violation at the
dealership it was unrelated to the
mayor's meeting with mr pirillo man to
be a fly on the wall you know because
laurie lagford walked in there and you
know she's got that raspy voice she's
like listen you got a couple of [ __ ]
watch stones shut your mouth
shut your [ __ ] mouth you got
beautiful cars outside you got bentley's
got lamborghinis you got all this [ __ ]
and you got a couple [ __ ] watches
aren't you insured you don't have
insurance for that
what the [ __ ] are you doing
you some kind of rat
you're blaming us on the city we got all
these [ __ ] problems you got covered
you know she went at him
she went at him hard
and then she called up one of her goons
and had the goon go in there with a
ticket book
and cite this guy four tickets for six
violations during her visit shortly
after 2pm
yeah only one ticket and two of the
alleged violations are health related
which means the whole thing's fake
and laurie was just like how this is so
now he's going hard at laura uh is there
a poll with an approval rating for lori
lightfoot
i mean
when was this so this was june 4. 48 of
chicago voters approved but that's all
fake too who knows who they're asking
oh here we go here's july because she
kind of went down really quickly she
went down quickly which is sad
cpa uh what does it say cbs police
department dragged down lightfoot's
approval as pritzker remains popular in
chicago yeah i mean i think eventually
people get sick of it
again it entertains me but i'm nowhere
near it
see gavin newsom's [ __ ] everything up
too but he's just not as fun
he's just some good-looking douchebag
who's indifferent to uh suffering and
death
but lightfoot is fun
so that's why i kind of get it
i get you know why people are fun i like
what she does goes down there gives the
the guy the car dealership the what for
and then has him ticketed i love keeps
hair loss you know why because people
lose their hair have you tried it i love
it i love it i have friends on it all
the time because their hair you got to
keep the hair you have you can't paint
your head you can't use those weird uh
toupees or hair regrowth stuff you got
to keep the hair you have that's what
keeps is good two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35. more than 50 million
men in the us suffer from male pattern
baldness they're only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps offers both
they offer a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't even have to leave your home
low-cost treatments starting at what ten
dollars a month to keep your hair wow
discreet packaging proven results keebs
has more five-star reviews than any of
its competitors prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act
fast
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash tim dillon to receive your fun
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon to
get your first month free k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash tim dillon
bluetooth baby everybody is in love
bluetooth unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
caplets at a fraction of the cost you
can take them anytime day or night so
you can plan ahead or be ready whenever
an opportunity arises the process is
simple sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part it's all done online
no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward convos no waiting in line at the
pharmacy blue chews tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discreet package with
blue chew men everywhere are excited to
see the postman because when your
package has arrived your package has
arrived
women say there's nothing sexier than
confidence and bluetooth can't help
giving you confidence where it counts so
if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help we've got a special
deal for our listeners try bluetooth
free when you use our promo code td at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code td to
receive your first month free so you get
your first month free they're a great
supporter of our show
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and as
always we thank bluechu for sponsoring
the podcast
massive california
train look looting prompts intense
criticism of democrats gavin newsom so
what's happening with these trains in
california is people are looting them
and trying to grab stuff from amazon
right they're trying to grab a nintendo
switch which ray kump got for me uh for
christmas which is very nice
and um
thieves in l.a are looting freight
trains like this is what you when you
have fat friends they just give you
things to keep you fat he's like here's
a nintendo switch never move
now you don't have to leave the chair
is the remote too
too stressful
thieves in l.a are looting freight
trains filled with packages from ups
fedex and amazon and look at this i mean
you see the picture
you could you could play that it it's
really crazy
but there's no real uh is there any like
is there any plan to get this state back
in shape here
doesn't seem like it
photos and videos showing piles of empty
boxes littered alongside rail tracks in
la county have gone viral as shipping
companies say they've seen a dramatic
spike in railroad theft old school theft
people are going to start stealing
horses next
union pacific one of the largest
railroad companies said it may avoid
operating in la county following the
spike in thefts which it blames on tax
prosecution unlacks
prosecution of crimes the containers and
trains are locked but can be broken into
yeah well they have the bail reform now
and they're not even letting sirhan
sirhan out this is why i have a problem
if you're gonna let everybody out let
sarhan sirhan out so that he can tell us
all about the mkultra program and he
could tell us all about uh whether it
was sydney godley where i forget it was
this uh doctor something west
rogan talks about it
dr jolly west the cia doctor was running
all the mk programs i want sarhan saran
to tell us
why exactly he shot bobby kennedy
because he probably doesn't even [ __ ]
know
so now gavin newsom
did he write an op-ed
why i will not release sir hans turhan
on parole yeah
so january 13th gavin newsom someone
wrote this for gavin newsom probably the
cia
and emailed it to him and then he uh
emailed it to the la times
so this is gavin newsom by the way who
cannot write and probably barely reads
in 1968 sirhan saran assassinated robert
f kennedy just moments after kennedy won
the california presidential primary
sirhan also shot and injured five
bystanders decades later shorthand
refuses to accept responsibility for the
god he didn't know he was doing it
you see his mind was hacked
yeah he doesn't accept responsibility he
doesn't know what the [ __ ] happened he
came to standing in the ambassador hotel
over a body can we find out why he was
hanging out with jolly west cia doctor
what can we can we get in there
please
well january's six yeah we get it okay
bad but can we also get in this
yeah of course he doesn't accept respect
kennedy's assassination not only changed
the course of this nation and robbed the
world of a promising young leader it
also left his 11 children without a [ __ ]
too many children by the way keep in
your pants without a father and his wife
without a husband kennedy's family bears
his loss every day millions of americans
lost do you think any of them are
curious do you think any of the 11 kids
are curious about what happened i bet
they're curious let's interview them
how about the 11 kids you don't think
they've stumbled upon the internet
you don't think they've read a blurb or
two that makes them slightly that
everyone in their family ends up dead
huh everyone in our family ends up dead
what a string of luck
so gavin newsom is denying sirhan sirhan
uh parole
and we want to know
yeah the board decided he was good for
parole and then the board goes let him
go
let him go
sarah recorded his plans to kill kennedy
writing rfk must die rfk must be killed
rf kennedy must be assassinated again
that's yeah sure that can't be doctored
nobody could rode that for him
google surrey has sir in charlie west
oh go back go back for a minute
go back for me incredibly in the 90s
sarhan began dodging responsibility he
claimed he could not remember the crime
hmm
stated he was innocent in 2016 sure hand
said he believed he did not kill kennedy
based on what he has read blah blah blah
suryan portrayed himself as a victim
claiming he was in the wrong spot at the
wrong time
um he's 77 years old so he's a threat
not the people stabbing the woman in the
carpet place
he's a threat he's almost 80 and they
think he's going to go out and go on a
shooting spree i'd like to know why he
doesn't remember the crime i'd like i'm
a little curious now google's sirhan sir
and jolly west
i'm i'm wondering about this and i'm i'm
unsure and somebody will correct me in
the comments or whatever but
this period of history i'm relatively
familiar with i just don't want to say
anything where people are like you're
wrong about that
um
but a lot of people believe there was a
lot of [ __ ] in there with with that
period of history where you were having
like the cia in league with cults giving
people acid trying mind control
experiments on and were they able to
[ __ ] a few of these people in terms of
like were they able to program these
people to commit certain acts why not
um so here
so
he remained interested in the subject of
mind control throughout his career as an
expert witness he examined a number of
high-profile crime cases that were
politically motivated or involve cults
after examining lee harvey oswald's
assassin jack ruby alone in his jail
cell
west jolly west concluded in 1964 he was
suffering from a major mental illness
thereby narrowing down ruby's possible
motives other people he examined were
sirhan sirhan
patricia hurst
and timothy mcveigh
fun
fun stuff huh
very odd when they when they find when
aliens sift through
uh the decay of this civilization
uh and they piece all this together man
are we you know and here's the thing
we'll all be dead and nobody will really
know and maybe even the aliens won't
even do it because it'll all probably be
lost but like if you ever got a full
accounting of why things happen in this
country and how they happen i mean
you think tv shows are good like you
think house of cards people like i
remember when i spoke to people who
watched house of cards and they were
like yeah that's a little dramatic and
uh it's a little unbelievable i'm like
yeah it's unbelievable in the sense that
like it it makes things uh far too
positive
it seems how many people did they kill
four like you have no idea um yeah it is
unbelievable in the sense that like it's
actually much worse um
this is true but we'll never get near
any of this right i mean nobody's ever
going to come out and talk about any of
this honestly
and it's very strange
they're just going to deny politics this
is a state who's letting everybody out
they're letting violent criminals out
that are young and violent
and almost certain to commit crime again
violent crime this is a 77 year old
who
they let hinckley out
and hinckley was a weird situation too
his brother
neil bush was scheduled to have dinner
with the hinckley family or was having
dinner with them
on the night that or the day that
john hinckley decided to kill
uh or attempt to kill president reagan
because he was in love with jody foster
what
strange
that's like me trying to kill gavin
newsom because i'm in love with melissa
etheridge
it doesn't make any sense
it's odd but hinckley's out and he's
doing music now
but they won't let
they won't let sir hans sirhan out
odd what do you think of the studio are
you happy with the beautiful studios
we're in the desert we might do every
year a different climate a different uh
terrain maybe next year we do a polar
polar vortex and then the next year
maybe we do temperate deciduous
maybe the other maybe then we'll do
rainforest i would like rainforest
uh you know we got to keep it
interesting and keep it fun
that's
that's the thing here we were some
people may be disappointed by the lack
of neon sign but when we have guests the
neon sign will be behind the gas steve
will do it from uh
nelk
the nelk uh boys
a comedy sketch collective uh moguls
uh they've released the happy dad hard
seltzer they're in the ufc area space a
lot they have a big podcast a full send
podcast steve will do it as their
breakout star who is a fun
uh guy
will be our first official guest
on monday or wednesday but it'll come
out next monday he's a big proponent of
our
podcast a big fan and you know i'm a
little surprised by that
truly in a in a good way
i'm surprised by that
i'm surprised that he enjoys this show
so much because it's it's not a watch
because watches are fun they don't talk
and they just listen and they don't
really talk about the news and you can
stare at them and touch them
but he
actually enjoys this show
i don't know how much of it he
understands he may just like the pitch
of my voice he may just like the way i
look
and the way i kind of bop around on this
i don't know what he enjoys about it or
not
but he seems to really like it he likes
takashi too i wonder if they watch
together maybe i don't know let's not
get greedy
but we're excited to have this uh guy on
he's very funny he's a insanely
hard-working he's a good person he's
always giving uh uh people money and uh
and crypto and venmo and
he is
he helps others
he
sees people on the street and gives him
a bitcoin or
gives you advice on how to gamble
i think that's good
and he drinks and and smokes and
he's a real
fun
guy
so
no i i believe that now kids because
what they do is if their people are
homeless they teach them about uh uh
crypto gambling
and i think that's smart
and and helpful
so he's coming in hopefully on wednesday
and uh i'm gonna do tana mojo's podcast
on tuesday
tana mojo is a uh
influencer who's a fan of mine and we
appreciate that
now the reason i like her and i've
always liked her is because she was she
was born in las vegas
now i imagine that people who are
born in las vegas
just die immediately
but this woman has thrived
she's figured out a way
to thrive
as an influencer
and only fans killing it on the only
fans
um
and she's funny when you listen to her
talk she's kind of funny
she did a thing about a stalker that was
climbing in her window and trying to
kill her and it was fun
and i'm going on her show because i
don't do any of the influence or podcast
i mean they don't ask me
um
you know but
like that high pass show and i i talked
a bit uh a bit about it on the patreon
mind-numbingly boring
it's just dull
these kids are they're i mean
i'm sure they're nice people
but here's the thing
that the real show is fun like they're
creating this thing that isn't real we
want the behind the scenes show us the
adderall
show us the drugs
show us the fights with the parents
show us everybody's [ __ ] talking to
demilios because they've got the real
money show us the real [ __ ]
but they don't do that it's a very
sanitized
safe
uh brand friendly
netflix event
we want i want kids on a
on the phone their parents go you're a
[ __ ] failure
you understand that
[ __ ] you you know what's happening dad
i'm getting my [ __ ] sucked right now by
three underage [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
what happened you leave the factory
early today you [ __ ] near-dewell
piece of [ __ ]
i'll send you 10 grand don't ever
[ __ ] call me again like that's what i
want i want people just to be like show
us the monsters
like literally the whole shows it's like
these kids have lamborghinis and
mansions and they're like sometimes
i feel that i'm not as good of friends
with everyone as i used to be
who gives a [ __ ]
kill them
here in l.a
light their house on fire
the reason you're not as good as friends
with them is because you're breaking
through
you're gonna be big
[ __ ]
what kind of [ __ ] is this what do you
live in minnesota you're in l.a take
your bentley and drive it through the
[ __ ] house
stop this [ __ ] stop talking about how
much you love your parents what the [ __ ]
if we want to watch a show about 17 year
old millionaires i don't want to see how
close they are with their goddamn family
you're supposed to be a [ __ ] demon
from hell
a like a tremor that crawled through the
desert with a
fang laden mouth just trying to [ __ ]
get brand deals and bleed everybody dry
nobody cares about your [ __ ] anxiety
for christ be
cool
is it too much to ask i'm talking about
getting cancelled and afraid how scared
you are about online mobs say [ __ ] it i
don't give a [ __ ]
you can't cancel this [ __ ] like dude if
i was if i was directing that shot i'd
be like stand in front of that
lamborghini and say you can't cancel
this [ __ ] and then put a put a middle
finger up and say [ __ ] yeah
i got healthcare
but it's boring
it's
why because it's not real why is
hollywood failing it's not
real
we know it's not we know you're not nice
you're 17 with a porsche
you're not
nice there's a scene where one kid goes
should we take the g-wagon or the rolls
you're not nice
and if you are nice what a waste
but you're not we get it we know you're
not nice
we know you're not thinking of other
people's feelings
we know that
and none of them really have some of
them have skills right like the alex
warren kid's funny and he has some
skills but like and then one of the
little huddy the one who thinks he's a
vampire i guess he does some music you
know but he's a vampire he's like a
vampire or something he lives in this
and by the way he really noticed the
real estate in this town is disgusting
these houses in moore park and encino
he's just disgusting caves where they
were where 70s era sitcom stars od'd and
bathtubs it's really grotesque um
and
what is this it's their house yeah but
that's not their house hold on
is this a new house
right here
this is it yeah that's it listen
is that nice
no i'm
asking is this nice
can you go to little huddy's house that
thing's terrifying looking it's a casita
it's like a casita
i don't know what the hell it is
it's an applebee's i think they called
it huddy's hacienda right huddy's
hacienda show that
look at that
that's a themed restaurant at disney
world
you would put tables and chairs outside
of that and serve fat taurus churros
this state
is a black hole when it comes to culture
i'm from the hamptons [ __ ] off
i mean look at that it's it you know one
of the kids in the show goes it's like
let's surfer kid with the he has like
his name's jack right he's like
terrifying so all he does is this all
day he goes
he just smiles like but he's very
uncomfortable you know what some people
smile like very uncomfortable his smile
is very uncomfortable it's like
it's very it's scary
and uh he he goes like this he goes yeah
it's kind of like the cheesecake factory
i love it just get fat
a lot but my problem is they're all
trying to be nice the last thing you
want to do when we're watching child
millionaires the last thing we want them
to do is be nice show the real [ __ ] we
want to see vicious attacks we want to
see families being destroyed we want to
see
because otherwise it's not worth it it's
not fun sorry
i'd rather watch lightfoot
i'd rather watch the lightfoot shake
down a lambo dealer in chicago than
watch these [ __ ] kids live in a you
know in a big uh applebee's and then
predate with a [ __ ] lazy river and
[ __ ] dolphin shooting water and then
have to go to bed every night going oh
yeah and they're also really sweet what
we know they're not we know they're not
what netflix probably has on the cutting
room floor should be the real show
that should be the real show the problem
with these kids is there's like 19
handlers around them at all times
telling them what they can and cannot
say right
many of them love trump
that's what's great many of them are
queuing on like we want that
we want 17 year old like addison ray was
kind of a big trumper and because she's
from louisiana and she's got you know
she's
she's she's you know
this [ __ ] likes a little bit of trump
but nobody can be honest because she's
such a brand now but we want it we want
to see addison ray in a maga hat
that's what we
want she doesn't support trump well yeah
of course i mean unless now you don't
you got money of course of course you go
to netflix gives you a deal i don't
support him now
but you did
but that's the thing most of these kids
are like right wing uh fanatics why
wouldn't they be they've got 12 trillion
dollars
they were raised on like inspirational
quotes and [ __ ] you know like why
wouldn't they be so that's a lot more
fun to see
yo like hillary eats babies bruh
she's [ __ ] babies
but it's a boring show i wish everyone
the best i don't think they're going to
get a season two
like that to melisha i mean it's all
boring
it's mind-numbingly boring
we want chaos carnage and death
and if you can't give us that step aside
like cheers coming back uh one of the
people in cheer is a big pedophile he's
a dark pedo
now do they address that because that's
fun
not that he did it but the addressing of
it
let's see
they have to right i mean
i hope they do it should be every
episode
the thing about cheer is these kids are
from uh
some who cares part of texas and they're
cheerleaders and they have like they
have like
two years and they jump around on a mat
and then they go work at sonic but for
those two years they have really good
lives and everybody respects them and
all the young girls in texas are like i
want to be like you you know and then
eventually after the cheering the mess
starts you know they start yeah you know
their boyfriend starts getting thrown
them into walls and things get real dark
real quick you know they start doing
kill tony but
how cheers season two tackles jerry
harris's sexual abuse charges the
season's fifth episode offers a timeline
of the 21 year old navarro college cheer
teams members alleged sexual misconduct
with two young teens uh eventually
leading to his arrest now this is monica
uh what's her name he's friends with her
she's a legend in cheerleading and she's
an attractive woman
and uh i i i know like her son i think
on instagram and she's an attractive
woman and she's a beast of a
cheerleading coach and everybody likes
her but and it's not her fault but one
of her star
uh cheerleaders was like uh
just laying in it
all over
in january 2020 nearly two years before
harris was accused of child sexual
exploitation and abuse in a lawsuit
um he was prominently centered in the
docu-series first set of six episodes so
he was the one of the main characters so
now how do they handle this can we uh
this contains spoilers of season two of
cheer
um
but the season fifth uh and middle
episode dedicates itself explicitly to
these allegations his arrest and the so
we're watching that one
season two of cheer fifth episode where
i'm in
his arrest and the eight counts of sex
crimes involving minors eight
he's pled not guilty
um
so what they do is they do a cheer
where they
support
having sex with people your own age
so they go like they do the thing on the
head they go they go no no they go
little little no no
no no
little little head head no no
if you're that tall tall then breast
press tall talk
i hope that's how they do it
aldoma recounted how she learned of
harris's sexual abuse allegations and
the initial federal charge of producing
child pornography during september 2020
harris was federally charged with an
additional seven counts in december
2020. i was on stage at dancing with the
stars in dress rehearsal for our very
first live show
the executive producer came up to me and
showed me her phone and asked me if i'd
seen the headline in the news that day
she recalled it was like an audi an
out-of-body experience at the time i
felt like i couldn't breathe i did the
show and then i went back to my trailer
i didn't even want to look at my phone
because i was scared i couldn't do
anything about it and i just didn't want
to read it she added before revealing
that the team had a meeting that night
about the news which she described as
being a tear-filled funeral
towards the end of the episode the
navoro cheer coach reveals harris sent
her a letter which she describes as
optimistic and features his desire to
become a motivational speaker wait what
towards the end of the episode
hold on
towards the end of the episode the
devorah coach feels that harrah sent her
a letter which she describes as
optimistic and features his desire to
become a motivational speaker so i think
that was the end of season one this was
what they're saying i don't think so
towards the end of the episode
this we're talking about the episode
i believe it's
like i think he's
wouldn't be great
i used to [ __ ] kids
but now
i realize that i had to invest in myself
you can do anything you want to do
i remember when i was trapped
in a prison of negativity i was [ __ ]
kids but then
i realized
that i could hustle
and grind and figure it out
wow
it's sad it's sad for him that he's got
this disease it's sad for the kids it's
sad for dead aldama she you know but
here's what's not sad for the viewers
we don't want
i mean i hate you know
it's bad
it's not good i don't even want to go
into this because it's like
you know it's like stomach churning
stuff he's victimizing children but
pleading not guilty but i'm gonna watch
that episode
because it's the only episode i'm
interested in because i don't really
care about cheerleading or these
people's lives
but seeing them all react to this is
kind of interesting
right
i'm not saying i'm happy it happened i'm
clearly not
but as a viewer to watch them react to
this to me is interesting
how does a cheer team handle it how does
a texas
cheer team
handle it
here's the real reality
he's a pedophile
did he take vitamins
did he take nad did he do nadra did he
do high dose vitamin c high dose vitamin
d vitamin d cures pedophilia
vitamin d cures pedophilia
if you take
vitamin d
zinc
saraton and an ivermectin
you start [ __ ] adults
goodbye you're courageous you're a wild
[ __ ] you have chances you're
smart it's awesome thank you for giving
me the strength to be a gamer and be
trans
good night
so far so good
my favorite comedian in the world i want
to have him on this podcast so bad oh
you love him tim dylan yeah and i i i
love this man i i'm not kidding you i
think he is the funniest man on the base
of this planet belief in anything is
really terrifying what is this guy this
guy's do you have a gun
[Music]